the cast by the way is minus Chevy is so
nice
my opinion
opinion the rest of the cast is like
there was an incident that happened he
made uh some remarks that were uh deemed
to be racist do you want to say that
line again you he was so funny
on the show when you look at what was on
camera it's super funny it's really good
he kept saying he didn't like the
writing he sometimes could be in not
great moods you know we have to get him
off out for the day he was someone that
did not want to be there for the hours
that we were keeping but the hour the
hours were the hours and they were very
long and uh but that was the show so
that that was a big problem you know
then he left the show under quite crazy
circumstances he goes like where's Joe
oh